joining me now is Ash Ashley Troxell a
spiritual guide and a psychedelic
educator from Denver and Luke n nadus
Executive Vice President of the group
smart approaches to marijuana
Ashley why should we be encouraging the
shrooms so I don't know that we should
be encouraging I think we need to look
at this natural medicine and the
evidence that's coming out that's
showing that mushrooms are safer than
Alcohol Tobacco and cannabis and have
the potential to help Americans overcome
numerous mental and physical ailments I
think we need to research this natural
medicine and give Americans the
opportunity and freedom to use natural
medicine to heal and overcome their
Mental Health
crisis well natural medicine I'm not
against at all um but one 144 year-old
mushroom enthusias mom pushed back on
her critics recently Luke watch this
people say to me oh well like mushrooms
are you know the mommy's new little
helper that is not what micro doing is
micro doing is mommy is present and
aware and showing up maybe for the first
time
ever Luke what's going on in our society
that we have to lean on drugs in order
to be quote present for our
children yeah Laura thank you for having
me on um let's just put it this way big
drugs Inc and the drug pushers that are
out there trying to normalize drug use
across this country are creating what I
think is one of the greatest threats to
Public Safety of this generation um you
have the headlines you were just reading
out they're saying it helps you do
better with work if you uh you know use
these psychedelic mushrooms well ask the
cockpit uh the the the the pilot in the
cockpit who literally was tripping off
of psychedelic mushrooms for 48 hours
and try to crash the Alaskan Airlines
plane with people in it um then they say
it's medicinal it helps our veterans
with their PTSD that's the latest thing
we're hearing ask the veteran who just
shot had a mass shooting last year at
the music festival in Washington state
who was using magic shrooms we cannot
normalize these immensely potent highly
dangerous drugs these are not natural
medicines as Ashley says that we're just
pulling out of the the garden in the
backyard um these are highly potent
powerful drugs that rewire your brain
and there's an industry out there that
wants you to try a little bit this micro
doing which totally unscientific they
want you to try a little bit so they can
rewire your brain and get you hooked and
make a profit off of you we've got to
reject this push to normalize drug use
across our country Ashley um when people
say micro doing who's doing the dosing
and what is micro it all seems quite
subjective well a micro do is a sub
perceptual amount and so generally
that's going to be about on tenth of a
normal therapeutic dose of psilocybin
mushrooms uh a micro do is sub
perceptual which means that you don't
feel like you took a drug I micro do to
overcome my anxiety PTSD fibromyalgia
Hashimoto um and endometriosis and I've
been micro doing for two years now and
have completely gotten off
Pharmaceuticals um this has completely
transformed my life and so what a micro
do does for me is it helps me tune
into um my body and help me notice
what's going on and address those
problems lots of people think they're
going to take a micro do and it's going
to heal everything but you need to do
the work and Denver is doing the work
we're leading the way in um psilocybin
decriminalization and this zybin panel
actually reviews this each year and so
we decriminalized mushrooms in 2019 in
Denver and at the last cybin review
panel meeting they the law enforcement
and health authorities did not have
aders events to report
unlike got your point let's let luk l l
respond quickly yeah what she's saying
is totally unscientific and while at the
same time she's saying it doesn't cure
everything she's also saying it does
cure everything she's listed off of a
host of ailments that these um
substances supposedly cure and let's
like you know this isn't the first time
we've discovered magic mushrooms okay we
the 1970s happened we learned from that
it didn't solve all of society's ills it
didn't cure everyone's illness is so we
know what these substances do we've been
studying them for decades in this
country um if there are any uh you know
ways that these can be helpful medically
the FDA is doing that research but I got
to tell you giving people these highly
potent powerful mind-altering drugs to
use at home the only people that
benefits is the industries that are
selling these products and want to have
a chance to sell them widespread across
the country we have billionaires and
hedge funds that have put hundreds of
millions of dollars in these they don't
want any of these stories coming out
yeah well there's a lot of money to made
people I me I'm glad Ashley you're doing
well but um people are going to make
billions of dollars if they have
anything to say about this mushroom
Coca-Cola next all right Ashley and Luke
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else